bonjour katia vous suivez son cortège
parisien qui doit s'élancer de la place
de l'opéra
direction le palais bourbon on a dû
constater que c'est fait zéro absolument
la vie pour le moment il y à des prises
de parole sur la place de l'opéra
je rappelle cette mobilisation a été
lancée à l'appel de trois syndicats fo
sud et solidaires ils ont été rejoints
ici parrain des coordinations étudiantes
et des gilles et je dois aussi des
avocats donc plusieurs professions sont
au rendez vous en un jour évidemment ce
symbolique puisque c'est le jour de
l'examen du projet de loi de la réforme
des retraites qui a lieu aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée
donc il était important pour de nombreux
grévistes d'être là
la place de l'opéra ont le souffle on se
souvient a été le lieu de diverses
divers rassemblements diverses actions
comme la semaine dernière avec cette
réunion concernant les professions à
risques les professions pénibles et
actuellement donc je suis avec ingres et
17,1 un militant et délégué syndical cgt
qui a tenu à être là aujourd'hui
pourquoi c'est important d'être vous
d'être d'être ici vous dites moselle
vous christian christian pas assez
important de venir aujourd'hui parce que
c'est l'examen de la loi
nous on est pour le retrait de cette loi
donc c'était important de venir et de
rappeler que la démocratie elle est ici
elle est dans la rue elle est par
l'assemblée nationale voulait le choix
d'itinéraires de vous irait jusqu'à
l'assemblée aujourd'hui pour faire
pression montrer votre détermination à
vous opposer à cette a7 est sûre
remarchera jusqu'à l'assemblée et on
organisera une assemblée devant
l'assemblée nationale pour montrer qu'on
est là et qu'on est vraiment pour le
retrait de cette réforme
pure et simple ordonné comme le retrait
quoi cette réforme vous impact vous vous
travaillez dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire dans le privé qu'est ce
qu'elle va changer vos professions mais
pour moi j'ai 28 ans avec cette réforme
je dois travailler jusqu'à 67 ans avec
une rêver avec une pension de merde
j'aurais rien donc moi je suis pas
daccord d'utrecht à 67 ans avec des
métiers pénibles comme le mien on porte
des charges l'eau on travaille la nuit
on travaille les week-ends on peut pas
prêt jusqu'à 67 ans nous on veut
tragique à 60 ans pas plus
[Musique]
vous trouvez que toutes les négociations
qui a eu avec les 110 cas aujourd'hui
notamment sur la question de la
pénibilité noms n'ont servi à rien oui
ça sert à rien sincèrement ça sert à
rien nous on veut le retrait de cette
réforme et on va améliorer le système
actuel on vous porter aussi un autre
message vous venez de moselle là bas
vous rencontrez d'autres problèmes il ya
évidemment cette réforme des retraites
qui vous menace dites vous mais aussi
d'autres soucis dans la région laquelle
sont bien sûr nous on vient de moselle
donc c'est important de venir
aujourd'hui on est ami avec tout un bus
on était une centaine est revenue et
c'est important pour moi parce qu'en
moselle
certains la réforme des retraites mais
il ya aussi les destructions d'emplois
ont subi des pse on entend que le
chômage baisse
mais le notre région on a un des taux de
chômage les plus hauts de france donc
c'est important qu'on soit là parce
qu'on revendique aussi pour de l'emploi
revendique pour tous on en a marre de
n'être chômage de galérer c'est ce qu'on
vit en ce moment en moselle et c'était
important d'être aujourd'hui pour
montrer notre album merci on portait
donc nous suivons la situation ici lors
de cette mobilisation d'environ un
millier de personnes à l'appel des trois
syndicats sachant que de nombreuses
autres grévistes et des gilets jaunes
sont de la partie aujourd'hui pour
contester ce projet de réforme des
retraites
katia technique depuis la place de
l'opéra le cortège parisien doit
rejoindre dans quelques heures le palais
bobo merci katia